hello everyone I mentioned in my few
previous videos that I might briefly
interrupt the Bobby Fischer series to
check up on Leela chess zero so here it
is I'm briefly interrupting it last time
we checked up on Leela chess zero
she was the rated around 3000 during her
match with the Grandmaster enroute and
he or she faces a chess engine called
nirvana some 3100 rated or something
less 3098 I believe is the is the exact
rating I found an interesting game on
our chess calm article it's been played
in the computer Chess Championship as
usual the top engines stock fish
Commodore and stock fish krocomodo and
Houdini are battling it out who will be
the top engine but here we have a Leela
seems to be catching up to the to the
top engines and this is one of the nicer
games that was played during this
championship you will find a link with
some more information about this whole
Leela 0 thing in the description below
also going to the computer Chess
Championship I will be in the
description where you can check up some
more games if you're interested in in
top engine games so without further ado
Leela has the white pieces and we have
d4 on the board Knight to f6 c4 we have
e 6 knife to f3 the antonyms oh and as
in most of the human games the game
transposes into the Queens gambit
declined Knight to c3 Bishop to b4 the
ragas in defense and now Bishop to g5
pinning the knight controlling the
center we have Knight bt7 and here III
c5 we have C captures on d5 eek after
sandy 5 you can see that unlike
Petrosyan Lila doesn't have doesn't have
a problem with relieving the tension in
the center he capture Sun d5 and the
Queen to c2 Queen to a5 here Bishop to
d3 and now a move that when you're
playing with the black pieces you will
always want to play this move when you
see Bishop to d3 a d3 is a very active
square for the Bishop and here III
myself never play a move like this
c4 was played it seems like a very nice
move you force the Bishop away from this
very strong square
but here it doesn't really achieve all
that much I'm sure I mean a 3100 engine
played it so it's it's not a bad move I
just I just don't think a human would
would ever play a move like this but
okay
Bishop to f5 we have castles castles and
now g6 asking Lela what do you want to
do with this Bishop I do want to bring
it back to h3 or do we want to capture
on d7 so when presented with an option
like this whether to retreat on h3 or
capture on d7 what do you get
usually you don't want to capture
anything if you don't gain anything by
it so it seems like by capturing and d7
you will only improve the position of
blacks light-square bishop develop it
and connect blacks rooks so let's see
what happens if you play Bishop to h3
here you can get Bishop captures B
captures on c3 and here Knight to be for
simply this comes with a double attack
against the c3 pawn also now your Bishop
and g5 is threatened white would have to
react to this attack of the polymer okay
to see one Knight captures on g5 Knight
captures and here Queen would go back to
the 8th
what a nice tempo on this night and g5
and black seems to be perfectly fine
here also now this doesn't seem like all
that bad of a structure now the c3 pawn
seems seems rather funny looking so
after g6 layla decides the instead of
going into the variation we just seem to
go with Bishop captures on d7 and okay
Knight capture son b7 and the now comes
p4 an excellent move where if you play
something like pawn captures and Knight
captures you've just improved the
position of White's night there are all
these darks were weaknesses then I can
come to f6 and it would not be a
pleasant position to play for black on
the other hand if you think Oh
e for it seems like white just blundered
upon for example Bishop captures on c3
be captures and here simply capturing on
d4 Queen characters and here Queen
captures on c3 it seems like you've
grabbed the pawn and all is well but not
not so much for example Queen to e7 and
it's not all that clear how black can
start developing his pieces the knight
doesn't really have a good square it's
pretty important to guard f6 you don't
want to allow something like
to h6 followed by this on the other hand
if you don't move the night there's a
really no good way to develop the light
square bishop the rook is still
undeveloped and this rook is really
funny looking on f8 or just waiting for
this bishop to attack it so here if you
try something let's say Knight b6 to
start developing you you lose the game
immediately rush up to h6 and not only
do you lose the exchange here
the threat is of course Queen captures
and I fade with checkmate but there is
no square where you can move the rook to
you can to develop the bishop for
example if you develop the bishop you
simply get Queen to f6 and there's no
defense against Queen to g7 checkmate
so quite a terrible position for black
so after a for black tried Nirvana tried
Knights to be six to start developing we
have E 5 now of course you couldn't
capture now white to get the opportunity
and he expands in the center or she or
it but okay Bishop to a5 wouldn't attack
on the Queen we have Queen to d2 and now
comes rook F to C 8 a 3 asking what do
you want to do with this Bishop Bishop
goes back to a fade which is a very a
very natural approach you don't want to
allow any dark square weaknesses around
your black King so the trip to f8 a very
nice move Knight to h4 attacking the
light square Bishop on f5 Bishop to d3
and here we have the well a very
important moment in the game White's
rook is under attack and here
Leela pushes f4 and it seems like a very
natural move you know in a classical
game you would most likely play this in
a blitz game you would definitely play
it instantly because if you look at this
position though this light square bishop
on d3 black has it's pretty much blacks
only active piece okay brush up on a
fate is very nice I don't know if you
would call this an active Bishop with
the Queen and a5 not really doing all
that much the knight and b6 likewise
Rokon developed rook and c8 the bishop
on d3 is pretty much blacks only active
piece so f4 you don't mind if this
blacks only active piece grabs your rook
and f1 and you introduce your other look
into the game Bishop captures an f1 was
played we have rook captures on f1 and
now comes Knight to a4
or hoping to exchange nc3 and perhaps
exchange Queens but of course Lila did
not sacrifice the exchange to to go into
an endgame
so f5 simply continued the attack on the
kingside a rook the c7.r trying to
introduce the other look into the game
as well and also adding further
protection to f7 we have Bishop to h6
offering an exchange of dark square
bishop and of course you don't have the
luxury to do this after Bishop captures
Queen captures the thread of f6 and
Queen g7 is is too powerful if you try
to prevent it with playing f6 yourself
you get simply F captures and g 6h
captures and now it captures on f6 and
it's all over for example look to f7 you
try to stop the pawn but then Knight
captures you threaten checkmate on h8 if
you stop this Daniel yet f7 you have to
capture and you will once again be
checkmated on h8 so after Bishop to h6
Knight captures and c3 was played and
here we have Bishop captures on f8 you
have to capture the bishop you don't
want to allow Queen to h6 so rod
captures and now f6 a very nice move if
you tried something like recapturing B
captors on c3 is far too slow because
Queen captures on a3 and black will
defend now if you play something like
Queen to h6 a black can simply move the
rook and after you threatened checkmate
Queen can come to a fate that was the
whole reason of grabbing upon not just
the grab bonds so black defended and now
black is actually the one that's better
here
so after rook rook captures on a faith
we have f6 now a very elegant way to
continue the attack as the knight can't
move so the temporary pea sacrifices you
know not that important King to a trade
here we have Knight to f3 a knight to f3
is a very nice move because the
immediate Queen to h6 black can defend
with rook to g8 but it's very
interesting although this would not be
possible in this game I will just show
it because it's so it's one of my one of
my favorite ideas for example if this
was position let's say rook a4 and I'd
be 5 let's say black threatens Queen e1
for some reason
Knight of 3 let's say something is
played right here how do you how do you
win the game here with White's
I
I only did this to present you with a
nice puzzle so feel free to pause the
video here and find our winning idea for
white here for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent Queen sacrificer and for those
who just want to enjoy the show
Queen captures on h7 of course is the
idea you might remember it for your
future games after king captures rook to
h4 will be checkmate as the point is
guarding this square and the rook is
preventing the king from escaping to g8
so a very nice idea
regardless it's not you know in any way
connected to this game but you know just
decide I decided to show it anyway
Knight to f3 was played a very nice move
that now after the Queen comes to h6 the
night is coming to g5 and then the
threats will also be on g7 but both on
h7 as well Knight to e2 check you have
to give up the night this way to at
least get the Queen off of this diagonal
so now of course if you move the king
black will be able to exchange Queens of
course you want to capture the knight
but at least now the Queen is not on
this diagonal we have h6 trying to
consolidate with this giving back of the
piece idea Queen to f2 in preparing
Queen to h4 we have c3 and then out
comes Queen to h4 with threats of course
of Queen captures in checkmate
so h5 and now comes B captures on c3 you
could try and ignore this by playing
something like with the g5 but after
King to h7 there's no way for the Queen
to enter so there's no rush first we
captures we have Queen captures on c3
and now comes Queen to f4 a much
stronger idea than the Queen g5 because
now after King to h7 which was played in
the game at least you have this nice g5
Square available for the knight c6 first
now again we have a very nice position
here where you can't really capture here
because now we get Knight g5 check and
black is like this simply doomed King
moves f7 you can't capture because the
pawn is guarded three times King moves
Knight captures on e6 with the check and
here you're simply getting into into a
forced checkmate variation King moves
you can bring your Queen in the game or
on
night queen somewhat faster and there's
no defense against against any of the
checkmates here so okay after six we
have looked to see it and the now comes
east seven of course you couldn't
capture now but a white takes this
opportunity to push the point all the
way to e7 Queen captures on a three
there was no way to actually move the
rook so black as black is up the
exchange he tries to give back some
material to at least try and get back
into the game
now comes g4 and here you don't really
have the option again of moving the rope
if you try to move the rook you get the
G captures on h5 captures and now comes
Queen to a5 check King moves Queen
captures King moves Queen g4 check and
whatever you play with the king
you'll get Queen to G's g7 checkmate so
after g4 we get Queen 33 and Dena comes
Knight to g5 with check you have Queen
King to g8 and now comes he captures on
f8 now it's a very nice a very nice idea
because Leela goes for an under
promotion here capturing and the rook
and bringing a knight into game the game
not bringing a queen inter game and
someone already mentioned this I believe
it was during the game with engine
Sheeran that Leela there are trolls her
opponents but it's not I've read
somewhere that it's not a matter of
anything like that that it's a merely a
matter of conserving energy or something
like that I'm not that much into machine
learning but it's basically like if you
had a king in three points versus a king
in three points and I have a queen and
you have a look and if I know that the
king and ponen game is winning I'll just
grab your rook with the Queen because
then I you know I want to tire my brain
by calculating all your moves with the
rook so basically by playing this it
doesn't matter what you bring into the
game the Queen did not the rook the
knight or the bishop it's pretty much
all the same
and here Nirvana understands this and
doesn't even bother recapturing because
if you recapture again G captures on 85
is sufficient to win to win this you
move you simply make a nice room on the
G file for your rope
bring a rope to the G file and here you
would just win win the game easily or
with any other variation but okay here a
six was played and the now comes night
study seven and here the game is
completely winning for white it doesn't
really matter what you play here you
will still win the game
so here rook to e8 was played we have a
Knight to d5 Queen to c2 and now Knight
captures on f7 and here a Nirvana just
tried some silly moves to prolong the
game this is something engines will
often do if they're not programmed to
resign Queen F to check simply giving up
the Queen then comes rope to c8 Queen
threatens checkmate ng7 ends now after
rope c1 check King moves and rook g1
King captures H Jefferson g4 was played
and here I move 42 Leela actually
delivers checkmate against engine
nirvana so there you have it a very nice
game balilla just zero I do hope you
enjoy that even though Lee lies I
believe some two hundred rating points
higher rated than Nirvana
but you know a very impressive game you
know they even even in a human chest you
will very rarely see a game like this
even between opponents who are two
hundred rating points apart I would like
to thank Alton steely aloft or amoun
Dawson and Alfredo curry for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos your
thing call for watching and I'll see you
soon with another interesting video
perhaps even from Leela but most likely
continuing the official series thank you
all and I'll see you soon